former National Security Advisor Michael
Flynn thought he would walk out of court
free after a sentencing hearing
yesterday instead a federal judge
delayed Flynn sentencing after accusing
him of selling out his country the judge
lectured him and signaled the retired
general might go to prison for lying to
the FBI for now Flynn will get more time
to cooperate with the Russia
investigation
Paula Reid is at US District Court in
Washington Paula I mean what an
extraordinary hearing what a turn it was
such a turn Nora a packed courtroom was
stunned as Judge Emmett Sullivan said he
could not hide his disgust and his
disdain for Flynn's crimes 'no flynn was
seated at a table with his attorneys and
he looked visibly shaken especially when
Judge Sullivan asked prosecutors if they
had ever considered charging him with
treason that's a crime punishable by
death the judge later apologized for
that question
but Felina has admitted that he lied
about discussing US sanctions with the
Russian ambassador during the
presidential transition the judge called
it a very serious offense especially
because he lied during an interview with
FBI agents while on the physical
premises of the White House but after a
short recess a shocked Flynn and his
attorneys they just took the judge up on
his offer to delay sentencing while
Flynn continues to cooperate with the
special counsel in the hope that that
could convince this judge to grant him
leniency the judge wants a status update
in the case in about 90 days but that
means Polina likely won't be sentenced
until the spring gale
all right Paula thank you very much